نظر مواجهه او ساعه لحوم مجددا بين انقره
وخصومها من الجماعات الكرديه المسلحه فبعد
يوم من غارات جويه تركيه على قواعد تلك
الجماعات في شمال العراق وشمال سوريا
تعرضت مدينه غرغامش في ولايه غازي عنتاب
الحدوديه لهجوم بالقضاء اسفر عن قتلى
وجرحى
القذائف التي انطلقت من الاراضي السوريه
اصابت مرافقا مدنيه بينها بعض المدارس من
مقتضى تعطيل الدروس اسبوعا بحسب وزير
التربيه التركي اما وزير الداخليه فاتهم
حزب العمال الكردستاني بتنفيذ الهجوم
وتعاهد باستمرار عمليه الجيش التركي
اطلقت ثلاث قبائل في هون من الاراضي
السوريه على مناطق ماهوله في تركيا في
ساعات ظهور اليوم للاسف هناك طفل رضيع
ومعلمته من ضمن القتلى نؤكد ان العمليه
العسكريه التي بدات بالامس وسببت الكثير
من الخسائر للمنظمه الارهابيه ستستمر داخل
تركيا وخارجها
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ذهب الى
ابعد من ذلك متحدثا عن احتمال اطلاق عمليه
بريه في الشمال السوري للقضاء على ما
سماها المنظمات الارهابيه ولم يخفي
اردوغان تدمره من عدم التزام روسيا باتفاق
سوتشي الذي ينص على تطهير المنطقه من
المسلحين الاكراد
كمشتكى من استمرار الولايات المتحده في
ارسال الاسلحه والذخائر الى ما سماها من
طاقه الارهابي في سوريا رغم ان البلدين
منذويان معنا تحت مظله 2
التحركات العسكريه التركيه جاءت بعد اسبوع
من هجوم اسطنبول الدامي الذي حملت انقره
المسؤوليه عنه للجماعات الكرديه حيث
اعتقلت المراه التي نفذت التفجير واعترفت
وفق الامن التركي بان حزب العمال
الكردستاني هو الذي كلفها بالعمليه وهي
افادات تعدها انقره حجه ضد نفي الحزب
مسؤوليته عن التفجير